what up guys welcome to the just pearly
things YouTube channel and welcome to
Pearl daily where I cover this week's
treachery debauchery and craziness
before I start don't forget to subscribe
to the channel and ring that
notification Bell that way you're gonna
be notified of my daily videos like the
video on your way in let's get started
so today we are starting off hot with
the Logan Paul and Dylan Dennis stories
for those of you that haven't been
following the story Dylan and Logan are
scheduled to fight next month coming up
to this fight
um Dylan has taken it upon himself to
really dig through Logan's fiance's past
so Logan is engaged to Nina agdalis and
she is a supermodel and she's been in
the scene for a decade and really has
made quite the name and reputation for
herself Dylan has posted her with over
50 men over 50 different men uh we don't
know exactly who she dated and who she
did it but a lot of the images that have
been shared have been quite sexual um in
nature Logan really has been saying no
no these are long-term relationships and
they're trying to make it into something
else but Dylan on the other hand says no
no no you're trying to silence me and
you are basically living in delusion
your girl is a 304.
um so you know they've really been going
back and forth
um and you know she's been pictured with
celebrities like LeBron James
Bow Wow
um you know a Leonardo DiCaprio
so I mean this chick has been she knows
a lot of famous people I'll say that so
Dylan danis had a couple tweets today he
said they're attempting to silence me
Elon is one of Nina's former partners oh
Elon Musk
she didn't just make it into Hollywood
she made it into the billionaire
Community you know what'd be interesting
I bet Nina as I was thinking I was like
if Nina wanted to make money off this
I I would just do a how-to book how do
you get in the room I mean obviously you
have to be super hot but like there's a
lot of hot chicks that cannot get into
the same room as these guys
I'm like if I was Nina my your
reputation's already ruined you might as
well write a book like um Brittany
Renner did
I mean the chick at least made some
money off a book I mean
so this is just how I think okay I have
some epic stuff for you all ha ha can't
wait for you to see I'm nowhere near
running out of ammo I want to cook
unshadow band me Elon Musk now
uh he's getting four million views on
these tweets is this is this Shadow band
Dylan danis pulled over 2 billion views
on Twitter in the last 28 days Dylan
please I want to see your ex pay out
play I'm like well how much money did
this man make
okay so now he's got a picture of her
between a guy's legs
oh they really
um okay so now we got Dylan tweeting him
saving Logan Paul okay okay now and now
I guess another video of Nina's come out
with a different guy
[Music]
oh dear
Nina why would why would that be a good
idea
why would okay
I mean this is just showing a lack of
Shame
we really need to bring back shame in
this Society because this is just
getting ridiculous this is going to be a
wife and mother someday
and you know it'd be really and I'd like
to hear her point of view I'll I'll
invite her on I'm a nice chick I'll let
you explain all of this
um but it's really showing we're just in
a cloud economy like people will do damn
near anything for clout
so on Twitter Dylan has really been
speaking about how he has a nuke he says
a nuke picture that will absolutely ruin
the fight he says if he posts this
picture the fight will be canceled you
know Logan and him have been going back
and forth Logan says he's a liar
um and all of this is alive
but there's a video that's come out of
him showing Aiden the video so let's go
can I ask you a question like oh no no
no no I know why can I say that no like
who I don't know
guys this is heating up I mean guys this
is why women were supposed to be virgins
on our wedding day because there's a lot
of men where there's no evidence of this
and they might not know it because it
was before the social media age but a
lot of guys have wifed up chicks like
just like this
um and so this is why I really think we
gotta bring virginity back we're all the
chat all the men will only give marriage
to the women that are virgins I I think
I'm solving everything here
okay so you know speaking of crazy
ladies and women that want to ruin your
life
um there was a story that came out of a
woman saying she called Child Protective
Services on her ex-boyfriend and lied
about abusing his kids after they broke
up it was really bad because I was like
I felt so bad about it
um I called like child services on this
one I got I call Child Services on my ex
because he pissed me off and then I was
like yeah I'm done with this person
whatever like you know cheater
piece of lies about dumb he
had kids I called child services on his
ass and I like
fabricated everything and like said
certain things and they like went to the
door and like there was a whole process
like I don't even know if the Children's
Aid worker still visits them but she
probably does because what I said like
the way I Aid that you know like
real AI like
fake bruises type
careful fellas yeah yeah pretty crazy so
you fake bruises you fake and then
you just made like exaggeration story
and then on their on on his kids yeah
like so hit like yeah and they came and
they were like oh like
we're seeing stuff that your kids are
being abused you know you could lose
your kids
and I was just like
that sucks
yeah should have been nicer to me
wow and you hear that guy laugh
and this is so great that she should
have charges filed against her like
there needs to like think about the fact
that she's openly laughing on a podcast
about how she could just call Child
Services
and take a man's kids away you know
think about how much power this only
fans worker has
that this woman all right that I I don't
think historically would you would put
sex workers as the most credible sources
um
is being taken seriously to actually get
a man's kids taken away and it's so
crazy because women will justify
anything and you can hear it in her
voice she's like oh I feel so bad
um but then talking about how he cheated
and lied and so now
you're gonna get his kids taken like
that is the most disgusting vile thing
you can do to someone
um and women like this should be thrown
in jail immediately because you know
she's just gonna keep doing it over and
over again like women like that don't
stop they don't learn their lesson
because there's no consequence and the
reality of the matter is women have way
more power in society today than men
it's just it's a known fact
um and this idea that women are
oppressed in any way show me show me the
footage of a man being able to get away
with that
it's I'm telling you it's not going to
happen
um
and that's why we need to have prison
sentences for women that falsely accuse
men we wanted to be men so be men
um and this is why I say women's
inherent like nature really is to over
exaggerate and lie and some women take
that to the extreme to the point where
they're ruthlessly destroying men's
lives and it happens every single day
and it's way more common than anyone
wants to admit
um so I I really hope that guy got his
kids and I really hope that they prove
they can at least show this tape that
she's lying and a known liar because and
that's why I say the believe all women
movement was absolutely horrible it took
fathers out of the home it took Brothers
out of the home it took Sons out of the
home because now you're giving power to
spiteful women to say damn near anything
about the men in their lives and you
know you're essentially giving women a
gun during a breakup you know if you
take someone out there angriest they do
the craziest and you're essentially
giving women a legal gun Within no
consequence to do whatever they want and
men have consequences for things in
society if they go too far they beat
someone up or whatever
um they know they'll have to pay for it
because another guy will step in but
women know that we have a system that
backs up women to say damn near anything
and really when left to her own devices
um women just go kind of nuts and I see
it in the only fans workers but I also
see it in the career women the older
career women that were told to chase a
career over a man and you know now
they're coming out with articles that
say these sassy sophisticated solvent
women say they are struggling to find
other halves that measure up
um okay so we got
46 year old Lucy
uh 52 year old
Leslie
Julia 54 Laura 42 in J and 48 so it's so
crazy that women live to half a century
without any humility
do you see the language
um they're struggling to find other
halves that can measure up well maybe
you don't measure up I think this was in
2019 and the women over the age of like
35 I think only like a quarter of them
are unmarried or yeah I think it's only
a quarter so uh the majority of your
peers prioritized relationships at some
point
um so I don't want to be that person but
it might be you
uh very well might be you let's look at
the Twitter comments let's see if
they're very sympathetic there are men
that would take these women they just
have to lower their standards men worth
discipline says they moved on about 20
to 30 years ago
none of them look like they are young
enough to Bear children so they get the
leftovers their time has passed and you
know it's so crazy because even male
athletes kind of know when their times
passed right like the the NBA players
would be like okay it's time to pass on
the torch but women like that well it's
so funny they they blame men for a
lifetime instead of saying you know what
I pissed away my youth
um I made very poor decisions I wasn't
good enough for a husband and this is
what you can learn instead they just
point the fingers and say the men don't
measure up and it's like what what are
their careers really that's my question
well all my life I was sure being smart
and having a career were the only
thing's worthwhile about me I've never
been attractive at all have been
reminded of that from a young age now
I'm a gross old hag no one will ever
want but I guess because I'm a virgin I
can be yeah no virginity doesn't count
when you're old it's like I mean what is
a 50 year old virgin worth I mean she
can't have kids like Lolo Jones it's
like I'm a 40 year old virgin I'm like
well at this point you might as well
just lose it because you pissed away the
youth it's like virginity goes with
youth otherwise they just assume
something's wrong with you because it's
like
uh nobody made the cut in 30 years not
one guy like okay Leroy what were they
doing with the good men in their 20s
yeah and this is the problem
um a lot of women
think we're more attractive than we are
we refuse to settle and we just live in
delusion for a lifetime and older women
are really supposed to learn from their
mistakes and pass on humility to the
younger generation but what I see time
and time again is that I'm still blaming
the men it's always the man's fault
never the women's fault and it's like
we're either equal or we're not equal if
we want to be equal then be equal deal
with the same problems the men deal with
but if you don't want to be equal and
you want special treatment stop whining
I'm just I could have a whole series
called women whining again you know
there are men that have exceptionally
hard lives like literally such hard
lives um you know they work in oil rigs
coal miners and you just don't see them
complain
you know men really do they suffer in
silence their wife gets fat they're not
attracted to their wife anymore they
suffer in silence their wife doesn't
sleep with them for three years they
stick it out they suffer in silence
where women whine 24 7 about everything
that goes wrong everything that's why
you see all these Karen's
um coming out and just whining whining
whining whining poor me boo who
and what you you also see is a trend of
men not being the leaders of their own
household even though most relationships
the men still pay the majority of the
bills most relationships the men still
do the majority of the work a lot of
them help with housework in 2022 and um
what you see is the women going more off
the rails because men have no Authority
and a lot of times the women don't
respect the men in the household so you
see the daughters not respecting them
either and that's why you see cases like
this come up um there's a girl named
Camilla who's actually promoting her
only Fan's work by using her brother
um and she was a woman from Mr BEAST's
squid game video
oh dear God
in the modern landscape of the
cyberspace you need to get creative when
it comes to promoting your brand or your
product and I want to introduce you to a
lady who's on the front lines of
innovation a true Pioneer to promote her
only fans her name is Camilla and she's
been making headlines this week because
of one very degenerate marketing
strategy she had for her only fans work
and every headline reporting this called
her the girl from Mr B's squid game
which was really baffling to me because
I didn't recall there being like some
kind of front and center Superstar girl
from the Mr B squid games so I looked
into it and apparently she had like a
very brief appearance in that video and
a bunch of curious coomers looked her up
praying she hadn't only fans and it kind
of blew her up as all of you know I was
front and center of The Hunger Games
Mockingjay Part 1 with my iconic
performance as District 8 Hospital
Helper and that experience helped
Elevate and Propel my presence online
very similar to her start however are
paths diverged whereas she went to
showing her butthole I went to talking
about butthole so on the forked road we
went our separate ways and now she's
making some weird choices when it comes
to how she promotes her only fans so the
one that got her in a lot of hot water
is this one how does it feel to have a
sister that has an of my friends always
ask me if it's pink but I don't really
know what they mean by that
do you know
click the link in my bio just I can't it
should be pretty obvious why this was
disturbing and upsetting for most people
she's using her brother who is a child
to promote her only fans content that is
some Twisted so she has him say
that his friends tease him and ask if
it's pink which is talking about her
vagina so this pizza's going viral on
Twitter right now so I figured I'd call
my brother and just check on him and see
how he's doing it's not looking too good
so
thank you
click the link in my bio so I can say
bro is he like actually it's the
craziest thing that's ever happened to
you since your you know older cousin
does of one of my brother's older
friends showed me a picture of something
you posted how did that make you feel
just awkward at the moment
yes 15 minutes with me what would you do
always been curious what it'd be like to
be with the woman you have 15 minutes
for me what would you do well you know
uh and then she also has one where she
does kiss or slap game with grand Mammy
old Memaw would you rather kiss or slap
her granddaughter's ass it's so
up
okay guys
I I just I really think I'm speechless
I'm speed I don't even know what to say
to this like
and you can you can see the men getting
like demasculated in front of our eyes
you know I and you know maybe now this
is public right she's doing these like
crazy public interviews with the guys in
her house but like men don't generally
like social media so when you see these
guys getting paraded all over these
chicks social medias it's not generally
their first choice
um and it just can't and it just kind of
goes to show that men are told they have
no authority over the women in their
lives I mean you can tell what those
guys are thinking they think she's an
idiot but
um but they're told that she can do what
she wants it's her body she's over the
age of 18. women really we do need
protection and guidance
um but the unfortunate part is we've
told men they can't give it to us and
we've demasculated men to the point
where they don't even want to
um and we don't listen a lot of times
when they do give it to us
um and so a lot of guys just decide to
shut up and stop talking and you know
we and we see it in these little
instances of her taking this to the
extreme right but I see this in family
Dynamics all the time where the dad's
kind of stopped giving their opinion
because the women in the family don't
take it and the women are always told
they're right and the women
um and the women really are leading the
household and when women lead households
it it leads to destruction
um and just promoting incest at all oh
so disgusting
oh my gosh that is so gross so we really
are in an attention economy where
attention is the only thing that matters
right now and you really see just how
attention addicted women are I mean I
I've said it before and I'll say it
again the women of 2023 are the
equivalent of sex addicted men because
we are so addicted to attention we take
off our clothes we now are insinuating
in SAS we ruin our brothers lives our
cousins lives
um all for what attention a little bit
of money and you you see women throwing
away their whole entire lives for what
to to sell pictures of your butthole for
5.99 it's just insane
yeah and I I think this goes back and I
think this is why social shame is so
important and a lot of times like the
right and the left will come at me
because I say hey guys we need to shame
not waiting till marriage there are too
many consequences for not waiting till
marriage mention Mary virgins like
whenever I imply that there is a
consequence for the decisions that us
women have made
um
it the innate instinct is to protect the
women from the consequences of their
actions if I say hey if a woman lied
about the paternity of the father
shouldn't she go to jail well maybe
that's that's too far and that's that's
the problem we're either equal or we're
either equal or we're not
um we're either gonna face the
consequences of our actions or we're
gonna keep getting bailed out and I'm
sorry but women respond really well to
social shame there's a reason we had
such big social shame barriers in place
throughout all of history but the
problem is the right and the left coddle
women to Eternity so we don't ever have
any consequences for our actions and I
think that's really
um what we're going to keep seeing is
the downfall of society female
promiscuity is linked to every single
problem in society you know the more
Partners a woman has the less likely
she's going to be happy in marriage or
even get married and
um what happens when the women divorce
or the women are or the women are single
mothers that leads to more criminals
more kids run away from home more kids
drop out of school more kids are in
mental institutions every big problem in
society we really can trace
um to single mother homes there's a
reason we have phrases like daddy issues
and the real rad pills the daddy issues
aren't daddy issues usually they're
mommy issues because she can't pick a
good manner she trashes the good man
that she picked typically I I really
hope that someone in this girl's life
has the sense to just shake her and you
know really I just doubt anything will
change but
I don't know oh God guys it's this is
just sad okay so there's an account on
Twitter called rivolino that claims that
he can predict if couples are going to
break up based on their body language so
he really breaks down the masculine and
the feminine body language so let's pull
up a picture
so right here he's broken down um
Rihanna and ASAP Rocky okay because
she's leading
her chest is out her shoulders are are
bad you know so funny
my friend or I think it was my sister or
something I was trying to improve my
Instagram pictures and they're telling
me you have to have your shoulders back
but maybe that's wrong maybe that's
dominant I don't know hard face
he's got a soft face okay but the the
key thing is who's leaning into who I
guess the more dominant person
um
or the LA I guess the less dominant
person leans in so if it's the guy it's
a bad sign it's headed to break up
Rihanna is pregnant with her second
child
um but there was a lot of rumors around
her throughout the years so I wouldn't
be um
shocked if they broke up but okay Jada
and will okay open legs
okay so we got not smiling
not leaning in that's the big one
um legs open the
facing the world okay so wide legs are
bad
um for the girl anyway the guy I think
that's okay Crossing his legs oh
sneakers are a negative okay ugly
sneakers
she's already looking for the next guy
uh too much makeup a choker tits
out I mean she did do a porno okay
that's that's fair that's a fair his
arms should be around her neck wow he
predicted okay I I thought they would
get divorced because she dated um
Leonardo Dicaprio and that just seems to
be the kiss of death on relationships so
she's leaning out and he's leaning in
that's that's a no-go if she's leaning
away she's not gonna stay
Alpha Donald beta Barack although Donald
has been married three times I'll say
that where Brock stayed married but I
think it more indicates who has the
power in the relationship and that's the
one thing people don't realize outside a
red pill some people stay married but it
doesn't mean they're relationship
Dynamic is healthy
um because it's really not healthy to
have a man following a woman's lead in a
relationship it just doesn't work I mean
look look what look what look what has
happened when Society has followed
women's lead the last hundred years it's
like we've got more government spending
more abortions more crime more inflation
like ever since the politicians have
catered to women it's just gone downhill
we're never happy okay well you know I I
thought this was really interesting I
think I think I'm going to cover this
again in a another episode and then we
can guess if I got them right or wrong
let me know in the comments what you
guys think is this true or is this is he
just kind of making it up all right guys
um you know your girl pearl
um has been getting some stories on
Reddit and giving my advice and you know
um
I guess you can take it or leave it
but a lot of these to me that I've been
given so far have just been common sense
but let's see today maybe I'll get a
perfectly like a tough one like a hard
what what should he do so
I walked in on my son having sex with my
brothers what
wow
I
this has to be fake this has to be okay
I walked in on my son having sex with my
brother's wife I-44 walked in on my son
having sex with my sister-in-law 34.
female a brother's wife in a cabin I
think they have been having sex for a
while my brother 37 male moved in with
us in February with his wife and two
children my husband 44 male and I have a
big house on a farm my husband is a
farmer and with everyone working from
home we thought it would be a good
chance to stay together as a family and
for my nieces to spend time on the farm
I have three children and all of them
live with us the oldest is 18 male and
the other two are 16 female and 13
female on the day my brother arrived I
went to buy groceries with my son and he
went to the pharmacy to get his gym
supplements and I bought the food I saw
condoms in my son's plastic bag when we
arrived at the house two packs with 36
condoms each so 72 in total I didn't
think anything of it I figured he'd
gotten a girlfriend and wanted to be
safe everything was fine and everyone
got along my sister-in-law and my son
would go on an early run around the farm
everything seemed normal until last
month when they left on their run but I
was up baking and I never saw them make
any Rounds Around The Farm which was
weird and I asked about it but they said
they decided to hit the road I thought
nothing of this everything seemed normal
my sister-in-law and Son seemed to have
a very good Bond yesterday I was coming
from a friend's house early in the
morning and the sun wasn't up and it was
a little dark but I saw that the cabin
we have in the farm was open and the
light was on I thought maybe one of the
employees had forgotten to lock up so I
went to close the door and switch off
the light and as I got closer I heard
people having sex I took a peek and it
was my son and sister-in-law having sex
I didn't confront them I was in such
shock I still haven't told anyone what I
saw and I don't know what to do should I
confront them should I tell my brother
should I tell my husband I'm so confused
I've been doing a lot of thinking and
I'm sure they've been having sex for a
while from the condoms my son was always
at the house and never brought a
girlfriend the morning runs around the
farm um do they really go for a run or
do they have sex and the close
relationship
modern women everybody this is why you
can't wipe These Hoes I'm like like you
see this chick is having sex with an 18
year old imagine if that was a girl
having sex with a 30-something-year-old
dude everybody would be in shock
um what would I what would I tell the
woman to do I would say to tell her
husband and do what the husband says
because honestly
um I don't think there's a right answer
for this but I think men think a lot
more logically women think a lot more
emotionally and
um you don't want to be in the middle of
this without your husband being in on
what's going on so I I would say ask
your husband
um rather than the internet I I think
you should go to your husband because
uh I really hope this is made up I I
hope this is made up for shock value
because I don't even know what I would
do
uh he's got a divorce the he's got to
divorce that for sure that woman
deserves to be divorced and destitute
you know how they say they don't want to
be destitute no we need we need her to
be destitute like officially destitute
um we also
yeah that son has got to learn a lot
he's got to get his ass kicked uh yeah
because you can't
that is that is just that is just wild
that is so crazy
um
yeah ask your husband your husband's
gonna know the right thing to do
um let me know what you guys think in
the comments you know I say she should
ask her husband but maybe you guys have
a better answer let me know in the
comments
um like the video on your way out and
let me know what you want me to cover
next on Pearl daily make sure you
subscribe also guys if you want a women
shouldn't vote shirt the link to that is
in the description if you want women to
come up to you left and right and tell
you what an amazing guy you are put
where where a women shouldn't vote shirt
today like the video on your way out
subscribe to the channel and I'll talk
to you next time